on the hill tonight for the giants will
be alex wood making his third start he
has been spectacular 2-0 with an 0.75
era with 11 strikeouts he gets one walk
in 12 innings
and when you take your bats against him
you're going to see a herky jerk motion
with an
outstanding command of his breaking
balls curveball slaughter combination
um he'll go inside and outside just as
easily as he will with his change up in
his fastballs fastball velocity right
around
low to mid 90s more lows than mids
if you take a look at what he's done
against the iraqis lifetime
he is uh
four and three with a 6-5-2 era and
there's been some times that of course
feel where they have gotten to him
and it's driven into right center field
ruff got a good jump
and the defense playing him perfectly
and that's how this game gets started
off the bat i thought triples alley
well i did too but the giants had uh
preset rough over protecting that right
center field gap just paid off mcmahon
hitting 273 with eight home runs he's
got 15 runs batted in
got him here he goes down below the zone
a little change up at 86 and he gets to
swing through strike three all of his
pitches fastball with two types of
movement the curveball slider to change
up he can go on both sides of the plate
with consistency that's how good his
command is trevor story hitting 274 two
home runs he's got 13 runs batted in and
here's the one-two pitch swung on and
grounded a third longoria's got it to
throw to first
and the inning is over three up three
down
uphill tonight for the colorado rockies
will be the right-hander
and armand marquez marquez 6-1 225
pounder he's 26 years of age
and he's in his fifth year at the big
league level he got to the big leagues
in a hurry why well he's got great stuff
you're going to see mid to high 90s so
on two pitches tommy lestella is retired
and that'll bring up the dangerous
brandon belt here comes don't swing and
hits a ground ball out into shallow
right field to mcmahon
and he slings it over the first
to retire belt
of 217.
he's got three home runs 11 driven in as
he lines this one to left field to base
it
he's now 8 for 16 against marquez here
comes brandon crawford crawford
four home runs ten driven in pitch to
crawford swaying and a miss got him to
go after the breaking ball again and
marcus gets his first strikeout of the
night
line drive base hit left field and now
dickerson is going to be held up welcome
to san francisco mike talkman well as
advertised you know work to count got
into it deep set up on the outside
corner a two seamer away at 96. the ball
had a lot of strike zone on it so now
the bases are loaded for kurt casalli
and the three ball one strike pitch
low and outside he walked in with a
fastball that forces home dickerson
with the first run of the game
one-nothing giants elya said something
to marquez after or after that
ball three pitch and then he put his
palms down as if to say don't rush take
your time and
he still couldn't find the zone three
and oh the count
to la stella and the right-hander throws
it's too high and he's walked in another
run and it's a four-pitch walk
two-nothing giants we could beat six
nothing quickly with the guy who's
coming up brandon bell 417 batting
average against heremon there's a chance
to do some serious damage but the bases
loaded
belt little flare centerfield bases
here's the throw home it's going to be
late
and it's four-nothing giants mike
cockman scores his first run let's take
a look at that challenge that man's got
hit me all over it as it is it runs up
the bat towards the label man that's a
good thing
man who struck out in the first inning
2-1 pitch is grounded toward the middle
front of his right la stella goes into a
slide and picks it and then pops up from
that slide and throws out mcmahon two
down
that was a heck of a play by tommy
lestella
i think he felt like the only way he
could do it was going into that sort of
feet first pop-up style slide
if his momentum had kept him going
towards center field i'm not sure he
would have had time to angle his body
back and make the throw to first so he
slid to
stop his momentum here's trevor's story
the pitch story lines went to right
center field tuckman on the move
tuckman's going to make the catch he got
a good read good jump and showed off
some real speed in center field
that was a nice play and alex wood with
a smile on his face
here's blackman
and the first space runner for the
rockies is a walk here in the fifth here
is jonathan dazza right-handed batter in
the o2 and he got him there's that pitch
that richarlia couldn't hit here's
fuentes
rocky's batting here in the fifth runner
at first the pitch swung out and missed
that's five no hit innings for wood he's
had seven strikeouts
eight strikeouts three in a row all
swing and miss strike threes so here's
trejo alex wood walked blackman with one
out in the fifth he really hasn't had
that many three ball counts
got him
best ball right down the pipe two down
guess and wrong that's the first called
strike three of the night
strikeout number nine
hamson is lined out to right and bounced
back to alex wood the wind up the pitch
swung on lined into right field and
that's going to
fall just in front of ruff who made a
dive for it then the ball popped off his
glove rolled away then as he scrambled
after it
hamson who's got great speed keeps on
going and makes it into second with a
double so garrett hampson with two outs
in the sixth breaks up the no hitter so
wood is getting dinged up a little bit a
walk of bloop and an infield hit
and this is an inside out sway that
produces a single to right one run is
scored rockies go station to station
it's four to one
capper coming out and he's going to the
pin and giants fans are going to give
alex wood a big ovation pressure spot
here for camilo doval giants scored four
runs in the second inning and really
have kind of been on cruise control
since then fuentes is struck out twice
and this ball back up the middle
and crawford on the first belt stayed on
the bag rockies get a run the giants get
a pair of outs and it looks like the
rockies will stick with yancy almonte
and pitch to mike talkman a former rocky
base is loaded one out
and a ground ball off the hand of
almonte who reached out to try to field
it it'll ricochet away and roll the
shortstop longoria comes in to score
talkman's going to get himself a hit
it's five to two giants
mckinley's pitch
flores pokes one down the right field
line blackman chasing after it's still
going still going goes into a slide and
lands fair he doesn't catch it
and it bounces up into the corner
crawford had to wait so he'll come in to
score now they've got flores who wasn't
paying attention hung up between first
and second
krone throws to story he throws back to
crone all the while talkman has to hold
it third
and so flores is out
for out number two it's seven to two
giants seven to three giants here in the
ninth
now a swing and there's a high
pop fly
second baseman flores into shallow right
he's under it now back pedals he's got
it and the ball game is over the giants
take the series from the rockies two out
of three